what is it do you think about this story
which makes it timeless or relevant at
any age great stories live on and that's
probably one of the most wonderful
things that we actually get to bring
these things to life and reimagine them
and sort of keep those words relevant
today when you talk about political Wars
religious wars all the things that going
on around us this is actually a really
really important film for right now
I was rewatching the 1959 version that's
so much about revenge I love the way
this one's more about forgiveness
is that something you enjoyed when you
got the script it was yeah I realized
there was such a massive change because
we were remaking the book we were
retelling that story which is much more
about forgiveness Marsala my character
kind of has not jealousy of his brother
but a desire to to make him proud a
desire to like prove himself and that's
what drives him down and then eventually
he leads into that terrible mistake but
what I loved is that it isn't that thing
of like oh the loss and oh he's gone and
I had this revenge in now I'll never get
to say I'm sorry it was much more about
it takes such strength to say sorry and
you really go on the journey with masala
Toby and Judah Jack and you've really
flew yet to know them a many points in
the movie you don't know who to be mad
at and who to like more you know
everyone makes mistakes and in the end
when they had the chance of revenge you
know the fact they take the story of
forgiving each other it's just so
important this book was written in 1880
it's been told multiple times the story
on stage on TV and on film as well what
is it about the themes of the story
which keeps it particularly timeless the
connection that's called that spiritual
connection between family friends the
inherent danger of being in the way of
the sort of job or not that the Romans
were at the time and the growing
excitement over the coming race is going
to settle so many things